on the crucial questions of whether the
21 victims of the pub bombings in
birmingham back in 1974
were murdered the jury here has
concluded that yes
they were murdered they have also
concluded
that they were unlawfully killed on
those two questions they were asked to
decide
uh whether they were certain that that
was the case their verdicts are still
coming in they've been asked
several questions um they've all one of
the questions they were asked was
whether they were sure
that this attack in birmingham two bombs
in two city center pubs that killed 21
people was it carried out
by the ira the jury in these inquests
has decided that yes
it was carried out by the ira now i'm
still
uh getting uh these verdicts that
they're coming out in the court at the
moment my colleague insiders
is telling them literally as as the jury
foreman is telling
the court of course the court is packed
with the family members
of the 21 people who died in these
bombings it was nearly 45 years ago but
for them
it is still extremely raw and they have
campaigned for these inquests
for many many years now we've had a
question
one of the questions that the jury was
asked us was a warning call that was
made
adequate for the purposes of ensuring
that lives were not lost
uh in the mulberry bush and the tavern
in the town the answer to that they've
decided is no that warning call was not
adequate
such that lives weren't lost and they
were asked if the adequacy of that call
or the inadequacy
uh resulted or probably caused or
contributed to the loss of life
and to that question they have answered
yes
now we're getting on to questions about
the police response to those bombings
uh the jury was asked was any error or
remission in west midlands police's
response to the warning call
probably caused or contributed to the
loss of life in these bombings
but the answer to that the jury has
decided is no
now they were asked did it possibly
contribute
to the loss of life in the bombings so
that they've also
decided no so deciding that any error or
remission in west midlands police's
response
probably or possibly contributed to the
loss of life the jury here
has decided that that is not the case